the
realm do you know what the realm
is it's the Thousand Blades of aon's
enemies a story we agree to tell each
other over and over till we forget that
it's a
lie what's up ladies and gentlemen
welcome back for another game of thrs
season 8 update video in this video I
want to discuss what game of thrs
writers and showrunners David benof and
dby said during a recent interview this
actually doesn't happen very often
because Dan and Dave have been hiding
ever since Game of Thrones ended over
four years ago well now that they're
getting ready to release their new show
on Netflix the writers finally had to
sit down for an interview where they
revealed some of their thoughts about
Game of Thrones final season as you all
know the ending of Game of Thrones was
arguably one of the most divisive
endings in the history of Television
after it ended there were millions of
fans demanding HBO to remake the final
season because of how much they hated
what happened during those last six
episodes well ever since Game of Thrones
ended Dan and Dave have basically gone
into hiding as a way to avoid the fans
backlash they haven't read anything the
fans have said about the show on social
media they don't sit down for interviews
about the final season and they've
basically done everything to distance
themselves from Game of Thrones in this
new interview they do say something
about the fans reaction to the final
season as well as reveal what has
happened whenever they do run into Game
of Thrones fans since the show has ended
now let's have a look at the new article
so you're able to see for yourself the
author of this article James Hibbard who
loves to hold Dan and Dave's hand said
Game of Thrones ended and David Benny
off and Dan Weiss had to figure out what
to do next the writers had made the
biggest series of the 21st century and
the most emmy-winning drama of all time
and it was their very first show HBO's
Game of Thrones had a spectacular
8season run a global phenomenon that was
reputationally marred by a 2019 final
season that fans loudly considered
disappointing in the online space at
least Ben off and Weiss's obsessive day
and night efforts to make one of the
biggest shows ever was Shrugged aside I
guess us fans aren't allowed to be angry
with how Dan and Dave ended the show
because of how hard they worked on it I
think it's fair to say we all recognized
and even acknowledged all the hard work
that went into the show after we all saw
the Game of Thrones documentary I'm sure
they worked very hard to get Game of
Thrones made but that doesn't mean we
can't highlight how awful their writing
was either he goes on to say
psychologists call this the peak end
rule how people feel about the end of
something tends to color how they feel
about all of it and many fans felt raw
about the end of Game of Thrones now I
have to disagree with this as well I
still consider the first four seasons of
Game of Thrones the greatest television
ever created I have never seen anything
as good as those first four seasons and
I'm not sure if I ever will again so
while I do dislike how Game of Thrones
ended it doesn't affect how I see the
first half of the show it's still some
of the best writing and acting I've ever
seen in fact even some of the scenes Dan
and Dave wrote on their own in those
early seasons are incredible he goes on
to say after the final season Dan and
Dave who never wenton on social media
and only reluctantly gave interviews
even when Game of Thrones was at its
height did what they naturally do they
went almost entirely media silent now
they're ready to talk about all of it
well let's just see how much they have
to say because he makes it sound like
they're ready to address everything
while I understand Dan and Dave not
wanting to use social media I think it's
unacceptable to hide from any and all
discussion about the show after it had
such a divisive ending they knew the
fans would hate it and that's exactly
why they Buri their heads in the sand
let me ask all of you this do any of you
actually think they would have stayed
silent if everyone loved it I don't
James does admit that Dan and Dave can
sometimes come off as dismissive of the
fans feelings well if you ask me they're
not only dismissive but they avoid them
altogether by shielding themselves from
what the fans are actually saying now he
goes on to say even if they secretly
agree age with some of the criticism for
Game of Thrones they feel it wouldn't
benefit themselves HBO or the thousands
of others who worked on the show by
saying so during the interview David
benof actually said you always hope
everyone's going to love anything you do
and it would have been great if everyone
loved it but they didn't you can get so
bogged down in public opinion that you
spend your whole day Googling things and
trying to find fans who felt one way or
the other now Dan we said even super
positive feedback makes you feel weird
and teeth grindy and on edge there's a
drug quality to the feedback and as soon
as we went cold turkey the last time I
Googled myself was in
2013 the ambient stress level in our
lives dropped by about 50% overnight The
Game of Thrones writers have even ran
into some fans in real life since the
show ended these encounters they say
have gone fine there is an underlying
decency when the fans acknowledge you as
a person and vice versa Dan Weiss said
there's always something that happens in
the transition from human interaction to
online that pushes things in a specific
aggro Direction when Dan and Dave ended
Game of Thrones many fans assumed they
deliberately rushed the show to an early
conclusion they had actually said since
season 2 that they only wanted to make
roughly Seven Seasons whether it was
ultimately the best strategy or not now
I will say he's right about that Dan and
Dave always did say they wanted to make
about 75 episodes however I still don't
understand why they stuck to that number
they had to realized that wasn't enough
to finish the story in a satisfactory
way George R Martin even begged HBO to
make more Seasons they went to Dan and
Dave and offered them more money to make
more episodes but they still thought it
was a great idea to end the show where
they did that I'll never understand it
doesn't matter if they always said they
wanted to end it after seven seasons
they had to see that the story was
rushed in the end he also says another
common assumption is that they left Game
of Thrones to make more money elsewhere
one of their little notice decisions
goes against that idea as the creators
of Game of Thrones Benny off and Weiss
were contractually guaranteed producer
credits on all future Game of Thrones
spin-offs that's basically a lifetime of
franchise mailbox money for doing
nothing on House of the Dragon for
starters and they say they turned it
down HBO was kind of confused benof says
I remember their lawyer saying but it's
just money we're just going to give it
to you Dan Weiss added I don't think
there's such a thing as free money for
us if our name is on it especially that
while being completely detached and
uninvolved it felt like the strin that
would come with the hands-off approach
with its success or failure or anything
in between was not worth it and no they
haven't seen House of the Dragon Dan
Weiss recently watched Game of Thrones
with his family but resists efforts to
get him to reflect on the result David
benof hasn't watched a Game of Thrones
episode since the finale yeah Betty
doesn't want to see how insanely stupid
at all feels by the end as we all know
Jon Snow set on the sidelines during the
entire final season bran went from not
wanting anything to suddenly wanting
everything Jamie Lannister was butchered
Danny was rushed and the night King and
his army of the Dead were swiftly
defeated before they were even a real
threat to Westeros now this article said
Dan and Dave were ready to address
everything but as always they avoided
getting into any of the real issues fans
had with the show now they'll move on to
their new Netflix series and most likely
fumble the ball at the goal line once
again now I will admit their new show
does look very interesting and I'm sure
it will be good if they do a faithful
adaptation however the author has
already said he knows Dan and Dave will
have to go in their own directions with
his story
so I guess we'll just have to wait and
see how they handle his novels let me
know what you think about the interview
down below are you satisfied with what
they had to say does it make you feel
any better about how Game of Thrones
ended do any of you actually think Dan
and Dave should be welcome back into the
fandom with open arms leave it all in
the comments I'd like to hear what you
have to say as always I want to thank
all of you for watching another video I
hope you all have a great day I will see
you again very soon
bye
[Music]